after a long day isn't it nice to hop
into a warm relaxing bath you can soak
up some suds and spend an hour or so in
there
now what about spending 167 hours more
what would happen to your skin how
wrinkled would your body get and how
long is too long for a bath this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
didn't leave your bathtub for a week
while resting in the water your hands
and feet start to become wrinkly
compared to the rest of your body we
used to think that the skin in hands and
feet absorbed water and that's what made
them wrinkled but research has shown
that vasoconstriction a narrowing of the
blood vessels in our fingers and toes is
the real cause it takes about five
minutes for skin to start wrinkling but
how much more intense would those
wrinkles become if you stayed in the
water for a week could they become
dangerous okay before we get to those
scary scenarios you can rest easy for a
bit enjoy yourself after all this is a
bath and that's kind of the point for
the first couple of hours you can bring
your rubber ducky and play in this nice
warm water yeah you'll notice wrinkles
starting to form but there's nothing to
worry about yet although they might look
a little strange and gross they actually
might be helpful according to a handful
of studies from 2011 to 2013 these
wrinkles might actually be giving us a
better grip in the water so if you
happen to lose your soap in the bathtub
the wrinkles might be able to help you
okay now it's coming up on 24 hours out
of your 168 hour experience and you're
getting a little bored your rubber ducky
is deflated your laptops dead and you're
starting to feel some pain you'll start
to notice bubbles forming on your skin
these are known as vesicles in this case
they're caused by the water in the tub
getting trapped between your outer and
middle layers of skin
these bubbles will continue to form
longer you're in the bath
creating bubble filled skin all along
your body and as that happens you're
starting to get hungry well it's
unlikely you'll have access to servants
while you're in this bath so your best
bet for getting fed would be with a tube
filled with all the nutrients you'd need
but then you know what comes next
you'd inevitably have to go to the
washroom you'd I don't have to do it in
the bathtub which would cause a number
of disgusting consequence no one wants
to know about or you could have a tube
that disposes of all this so yeah let's
go with that
but as you've been thinking of all these
crazy ways to cope with your bodily
functions you've been ignoring those
bubbles forming on your skin as time has
gone on
they've been slowly festering and
growing bigger this will keep happening
until a couple of days into your bath
marathon when they begin to burst okay
so now your skin is starting to peel
away and if you haven't been disposing
of your waste you'll be in a pool full
of fecal matter with open sores all over
your body yes this is the perfect way
for you to get infections all over your
skin glad you asked
now if this isn't enough to worry about
a couple of days into your bath you'll
start developing bath sores these are
similar to bed sores which happen when
you lay in bed for far too long since
there's not much space to move around in
your bath it could also tear your new
skin bubbles creating even more sores as
you're stuck in this bath most likely in
incredible pain you'll realize that
these sores have been distracting you
from something else that's happening the
water has been getting colder the whole
time if you haven't been adding in any
more hot water and you don't have any
way to sustain the temperature
your bath could get dangerously cold if
your bath temperature gets down between
21 and 26 degrees then spending just a
couple of hours in the tub could make
you pass out luckily it can't kill you
as the temperatures just aren't low
enough but if it goes any lower you
could end up dead
sounds like unless you're heavily
monitored with proper nutrition
consistent fresh water and some way to
go to the bathroom this'll end very
badly
I gotta admit this is a pretty awful way
to spend a week I mean who planned this
well definitely not our friends over at
Monday comm if we were using their
website maybe we'd be able to coordinate
the building of a spaceship rather than
suffering in a bathtub for a week what
I'm trying to get at is we could be more
productive Monday com significantly
boosts productivity not just for you but
for your entire team look at this
they've got a beautiful interface that
shows who's working on what when it's
due it allows other team members to
collaborate and helps everyone to create
their best work listen we get deadlines
we all do and if you work in an industry
with a ton of them Monday comm can make
it so much easier it empowers your team
to work their best completely
stress-free now even if you did manage
to survive the stress of all this you'd
come out a very different person I mean
with your skin ripped all along your
body and most likely infected it's
unlikely you'd survive what would come
shortly after you did get out of the
bath something you'd have a better
chance of surviving is if you've fell
into a pool of spent nuclear fuel rods
yeah really but we'll leave that story
for another what-if
[Music]
you